les seniors étaient les premiers sur la
ligne de départ de la vaccination
aujourd'hui ils sont loin d'avoir tous
franchi l'arrivée quand les sexagénaires
sont 88% avoir reçu au moins une dose de
vaccin ils sont 96 % chez les
septuagénaires la couverture vaccinale
tombe à
84,2 % pour les plus de 80 ans alors
qu'il s'agit de la population la plus
vulnérable face au co vie de 19 dans
cette catégorie d'âge plus de 600000
personnes n'ont toujours pas été
vaccinés ils sont la priorité des
priorités c'est une épidémie qui tue
surtout des non vaccinés les hôpitaux
sont remplis de non vaccinés les décès
tous des non vaccinés au sein de l'union
européenne la france c'est pâle figure
l'espagne le portugal l'irlande le
danemark ou encore l'autriche affiche
100% de vacciner chez les personnes
âgées de plus de 80 ans
97 % au royaume-uni et plus de 96 en
italie et à chypre en france la
proportion de personnes vaccinées chez
les plus de 60 ans est insuffisante de
l'ordre de 85% la france se situe dans
le peloton des pays européens avec une
position plus favorable en ce qui
concerne la vaccination des adolescents
mais plus vulnérables pour la
vaccination des plus de 60 ans la
vaccination des seniors patine mais
pourquoi une des raisons invoquées le
manque de confiance vis-à-vis des
vaccins quel que soit l'âge les gens
gardent leurs convictions il y avait
effectivement des personnes âgées qui
restent réfractaires à la vaccination
l' influence des enfants sur les
décisions des personnes âgées n'est pas
non plus à négliger ils leur font
confiance et certains refusent la
vaccination parce que leurs enfants la
leur des conseils voir leur interdisent
l'isolément des personnes âgées pose
aussi question certains n'ont pas
internet d'autres ne peuvent pas se
déplacer les services publics français
ne réussissent pas à identifier les
personnes âgées qui sont aujourd'hui les
plus exclus de la société ce sont les
personnes qui ont de grandes difficultés
de mobilité
qui connaissent des troubles cognitifs
qui ne sont pas encore vaccinés il
faudrait peut-être revoir le système de
santé et pour cause le médecin se
déplace très peu à domicile tout comme
les pharmaciens d'ailleurs depuis
quelques mois la caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie les agences
régionales de santé et les collectivités
multiplient les opérations d'aller vers
dispositif qui permet d'aller au contact
des personnes âgées et précaires éloigné
du système de santé oms vient de
franchir le million de français vaccinés
via nos opérations d'aller vers qu'on
fait pour aller chercher des personnes
qui ne peuvent pas pour différentes
raisons se déplacer jusqu'à la
vaccination c'est un million de
personnes qui probablement ne se serait
pas fait vacciner si on n'avait pas été
les chercher au pied de leurs immeubles
via des associations qui ont l'habitude
de les accompagner ça reste tout de même
loin d'être suffisant pour certains
praticiens il faut évidemment que
l'impulsion viennent de l'état c'est
évident après l'état doit trouver des
relais il faut que les mairies et les
départements utilisent leurs fichiers de
personnes fragiles ou dépendantes pour
vérifier qu'on est complet sur cette
population là je crains que si l'on ne
va pas assez vite avant le mois
d'octobre on est vraiment de gros dégâts
15 % des plus de 80 ans n'ont toujours
pas reçu de premières injections du
vaccin anti qu'ovide a malgré cela la
campagne de la troisième dose s'ouvre ce
mercredi